we can confirm that mr davidson is a  firearms licensed holder i'm unable to  confirm whether that was the firearm  that was used  second question sir was i apologized  there is no motive as we know at present  again that will be subject to inquiry  but we are at the moment not considering  terrorism or a relationship with any  far-right group or any such other group  but clearly he is on social media and  that will be part of the investigation  mr eve  um  we i can get that detail to you  certainly he was a licensed holder in  2020 but i will get out to if it was  held before that time as well  so as part of an investigation in this  or any any shooting we will look at  where a license holder was licensed by  devon and cornwall police of course we  will that will be an independent review  and we're making contact with  independent office of police complaints  whether they wish to do that or whether  it's conducted by another force and  we'll confirm that later